it's so nice to meet you but sad to meet
you on these terms i think i was like
wait a little bit longer at least
[Laughter]
[Music]
now that it's all sunk in how do you
feel today
oh i feel okay i even felt okay last
night you know what i mean i was like
this is really hard for me
and you know i'm just i'm happy i did it
yeah and how was your experience like
going into the house was it everything
you thought it would be
no
not at all and i prep so hard you know
like working out like trying to figure
out a strategy everything and it's just
you walk in there and it's all gone
so what do you think happened i mean
like my social wasn't the greatest
um and it was better later on in the
week but
the first couple days it was very tough
for me and how is going into a situation
like that especially right now where we
all really haven't had those social
interactions and then you're just bam in
a house with 16 people and basically
forced to make those conversations and
also how do you even remember people's
names within those first 10 minutes well
i know i know but it actually is easier
than you think
all of a sudden you're like i know the
names i woke up the next day and i was
like i know everyone's name
because that's all you have to do you
what i mean like name and communicate
with people
do you wish you made a bit more of an
effort with the conversations and just
trying to help yourself stay in that
house
i did
of course of course
you know
and when you were up on the block how
hard was that pov competition
i seriously
still think i could have won that
i but what are the odds like when can
you practice to
like do a six-feet puzzle
you know what i mean like i have never
done that ever i could not i couldn't
figure it out
do you think anyone's running the house
yet or is it too soon to tell
i think i think people are definitely
running the house
any names
i mean her mom had too much influence
this week like way too much and everyone
was just kind of whichever but then i'm
pretty sure there are other alliances
that are also formed with him perhaps
would you do anything differently if you
had the chance to go back into the house
i
it's so hard to say because my emotions
on the first day
it like i don't know how i would be able
to break out of that
you know what i mean but of course i
would i've hoped that i should have just
talked in the groups and you know did
more 101s and really like ask people
questions you know
and after getting to know everyone
who would be your dream alliance if you
could create alliance in the house with
all those people
dream alliance
without like anything that i've seen if
i could just pick probably
j
t
kyle
oh
maybe helena
because you you need you need a floater
you need an endurance you need someone
who can do mental you know what i mean
so
maybe you also need someone you can
throw under the bus and get rid of
quickly if you have to right exactly
exactly yes who do you think could win
it all at this point i know it's been a
short time but does anyone give off that
vibe that they could be the i'm like the
person that
wins it without even knowing
i know i don't know
uh right now
maybe maybe even moose but he's got to
get his like
honest game down like he was talking to
me and i'm just like nothing you're
saying right now is honest like that's
what i felt you know what i mean
but some people can't read that so
who was the hardest to live with
i mean
all of it all of it was just i just
don't think i had enough time you know
you see it and you're like why is it
every oh everything's so messy and then
when you're in there you're like
could not care it's like you know least
priority
did you have a favorite room in the
house were you able to adventure around
or did you just stick in the room where
you slept
you know what i actually really enjoyed
the pantry
and that was the room that i didn't
think i would enjoy
i loved it
going into the house did you have any
favorite bb can house guests prior that
you looked up to and you wanted to kind
of mold your game out of
yes i definitely there were like some
people that i wanted to take from you
know i obviously i love how dane played
their game in season seven like i just
was just a well-rounded player you know
what i mean but then i loved like the
fire of aika you know i mean i was like
okay melina tone that down but still be
yourself
um
yeah i'm blanking on the rest but
there's more
of course there's always more we have
lots of people but this is the 10th
season so how do you feel being part of
such a milestone season
i i i feel blessed for sure for sure at
the end of the day i wish i could have
stayed longer but i'm happy i made it
absolutely
and what is the first thing that you're
going to do when you get back to regular
life
right now it's sleep
without the lights and the cameras
watching you yes and no one telling you
anything it's just like i could just go
to bed when i need to
yeah
and are you going to continue to watch
the season and see how everything plays
out
i i will because i want to know if i'm
right with my acquisitions you know what
i mean
and do you have any messages for your
fans because there is a lot of people
that are devastated
myself included that you're already out
i'm so glad you know that was it's
always a worry you know um
and
i hope they know that
i was true to myself and i'm so thankful
for any fan
and i hope you know they see me on
social come talk to me my dm's are
always open
you